y
[Música]
las tropas rusas volvieron a bombardear
jarquín por primera vez desde que
aquéllas fueron expulsadas de la segunda
ciudad más grande de ucrania moscú
concentra a sus ataques en el donbass
mientras que ejerció en la moneda rusa
será una de las dos oficiales
en su viaje a china a la alta
comisionada de la onu para los derechos
humanos michelle bachelet irá a xinjiang
para investigar los presuntos abusos
contra los uigures aunque se teme que el
gobierno chino no la deje ir a las
prisiones donde están retenidos
desfile de estrellas en la alfombra roja
del festival de cannes en la jornada
destacan la presentación de la película
dirigida por el coreano que fue
protagonista de la famosa serie el juego
del calamar tenemos reporte desde la
riviera francés
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda de nuevo maría clara calle y
empecemos en ucrania por primera vez
desde que las tropas rusas fueron
expulsadas de la región de jarquín la
segunda ciudad más importante del país
fue bombardeada el centro de la urbe fue
atacado con un lanzacohetes que dispara
municiones en racimo según denuncian los
militares ucranianos esto a pesar de que
el arma está prohibida por los tratados
internacionales por su parte el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
afirmó que los rusos estaban perpetrando
un baño de sangre en la región del
donbass donde se concentra su operación
militar las ciudades más golpeadas de
manera reciente son slogans y
severodonezk mientras que en here son
una de las ciudades más grandes
controladas ahora por moscú introdujeron
el rublo como moneda oficial así la
moneda rusa tendrá el mismo peso que la
grivna ucraniana
uno de los lugares más representativos
de la guerra ha sido lucha y ahora
intenta regresar a la normalidad este
suburbio a las afueras de kiev ya
reabrió el mercado y los habitantes
intentan superar las imágenes de lo que
dejó la invasión rusa allí tras el
retiro de las tropas encontraron más de
300 cuerpos en fosas comunes o tirados
en las calles andrés granadillo tiene la
historia
paso a paso renace la vida en mucho con
una relativa normalidad en el mercado
los dueños reabren sus puertas
las tiendas se están abriendo poco a
poco las personas con niños pequeños y
perros están regresando es como antes
las carreteras se están reparando poco a
poco todo vuelve a la vida estamos muy
contentos de verlo entonces como digo si
no ves las ruinas prácticamente nos
estamos recuperando de todo esto
[Música]
los clientes aparecen de manera tímida
es un shock al principio y después te
das cuenta de que es nuestra realidad y
necesitas cambiar tu vida y seguir
viviendo llegue la vida sigue y tienes
que vivir sea lo que sea la vida sí
porque si no lo aceptas te vuelves no es
verdad la vida no debe detenerse está
claro que hay que recuperarla es
realmente muy doloroso lo que los rusos
nos han hecho y nunca ninguna generación
les perdonará esto docenas de nuestras
generaciones recordarán hasta la muerte
atrás quedaron las imágenes honoríficas
que fue el asedio ruso dejando el
cementerio de la ciudad abarrotado tras
su retirada de la ciudad el 31 de marzo
cientos de cuerpos estaban tirados en
las calles rusia niega que haya atacado
a civiles y acusa a ucrania de orquestar
una propaganda en su contra el
secretario general de la onu en su
visita a finales de abril instó al crema
a cooperar con la corte internacional de
justicia
es crímenes de guerra cometidos por sus
tropas cuando invadió mucha star box se
va de rusia después de casi 15 años de
operaciones y cerrará las 130 tiendas
que tienen en el país la cadena de café
se unió así a la salida de mcdonald's
que fue anunciada la semana pasada sin
embargo las decisiones son diferentes
pues start box se va totalmente mientras
que la compañía estadounidense de
hamburguesas venderá sus restaurantes
para que cambien de nombre pero los
productos se siguen ofreciendo las
decisiones hacen parte del bloqueo
económico contra rusia al que se han
sumado marcas occidentales como renault
o cel esto en rechazo a la invasión en
ucrania
alta comisionada de la onu para los
derechos humanos comenzó su visita de
seis días en china michelle bachelet
viajará a la provincia de xinjiang donde
occidente afirma que las autoridades
chinas han cometido abusos contra la
minoría musulmana de los uigur es como
trabajo forzoso o detenciones ilegales
la gran pregunta es qué tanta libertad
tendrá la comisionada pues el ministerio
de relaciones exteriores chino afirmó
que la visita debe cumplir con los
estándares de aislamiento para prevenir
el kobe 19 esto en medio del repunte de
la pandemia en el país para analizar el
tema nos acompaña patricio giusto
consultor político y director del
observatorio chino argentino que estudia
la relación de argentina con el gigante
asiático bienvenido a france 24 un gusto
saludarlo empecemos hablando de que ha
cambiado en china para que permitan la
visita de michelle bachelet
bueno en principio la única razón por la
cual china está dejando entrar a
bachelet en este momento es una decisión
de restringir las medidas por la
pandemia para el ingreso de funcionarios
de esta jerarquía de organismos
internacionales pero recordemos que
tuvimos los juegos olímpicos de invierno
al principio del año donde un montón de
presidentes y otro funcionario de
distintos países ingresaron así que no
está muy claro porque en este momento sí
y anteriormente no más allá de la excusa
de la pandemia pero lo cierto que las
autoridades chinas se están mostrando
una mejor predisposición y le han
abierto las puertas a bachelet quien no
va a tener que hacer cuarentena y va a
poder transitar por tres ciudades chinas
según la agenda que tiene prevista y
estados unidos ha criticado previamente
a michelle bachelet argumentando que
ella no ha defendido a los uigures que
pensaba que entonces le envía a la
comisionada a washington con su viaje y
sus investigaciones
bueno el problema que bachelet tiene que
hacer un equilibrio diplomático como
cualquier funcionario que está en esa
posición en este caso alta comisionada
derechos humanos porque hay algunos
países como los eeuu y sus principales
aliados que han hablado de genocidio en
la región autónoma uygur de xinjiang y
hay otros países que son la mayoría de
los miembros de la onu que no han
utilizado este término y hay algunos que
han quedado en una situación intermedia
diciendo que hay abusos que merecen ser
investigados entonces bachelet tiene que
hacer de alguna forma una tarea
diplomática
digamos de alta sensibilidad por los
lugares donde ella va a transitar donde
hasta ahora ningún funcionario de esta
talla ha transitado y la gran pregunta
es qué es lo que va a abrir china para
que bachelet pueda ver le va a abrir
todo va a permitir que ella se maneje de
manera independiente como supuestamente
se ha dicho y segundo bachelet luego
hacer un reporte
veremos qué contenido hay en ese reporte
si ella cuenta todo lo que vio
con el tenor que muchos países como los
eeuu están esperando y ustedes
precisamente habla de la gran pregunta
que es la que le quiero hacer y es que
tan posible es que china le permita a
michelle bachelet que visite los lugares
de detención y si no la dejan que tanto
efecto tendría su visita
bueno si no la dejan y si es una visita
muy restringida que es quizás la
principal hipótesis de lo que puede
suceder esto no va a tener mucho mayor
sentido más que el informe de bachelet
al terminar la gira y que esto va a
hacer que recrudezcan las críticas que
de vuelta se vuelva a hablar con mucho
énfasis sobre esta cuestión pero no va a
cambiar nada en china ahora si
efectivamente bachelet puede recorrer
los supuestos centros de detención que
están denunciados básicamente en
publicaciones periodísticas no olvidemos
esto lo interesante sería que bachelet
pueda constatar de alguna forma la
veracidad de todo eso pero ella se hizo
una advertencia dijo esta no es un
investiga un viaje de investigación sino
que es una visita en mi carácter de
diplomática en este cargo que se ocupa
en la onu y ya anticipo de una forma
bajando las expectativas de que no va a
haber una gran y gerencia directa de lo
inmediato en lo que pueda surgir de este
viaje así que lamentablemente son más
interrogantes que certezas lo que
tenemos con esta gira de bachelet que
acaba de comenzar en china patricio y ya
esperaremos que pasa con estas
incertidumbres de las que usted nos
habla gracias por estar con nosotros en
france 24
muchas gracias y cambiamos de noticia
porque estados unidos está dispuesto a
involucrarse militarmente si china
invade a la región autónoma de taiwán
así lo afirmó el presidente joe biden
desde tokio donde se reunió con el
primer ministro japonés fumiyuki sida es
que el presidente estadounidense está en
una gira de cinco días por corea del sur
y por el país nipón para afianzar sus
relaciones en el indo pacífico una zona
con la que se disputa el poder
geopolítico con china de hecho by the
end lanzó un nuevo acuerdo comercial con
12 naciones del indo pacífico ante la
alta inflación pero que de paso mejorar
las relaciones con los influyentes de la
región como australia o india
japón también es un líder mundial clave
que trabaja con nuestros socios del g7
para responsabilizar a putin por su
guerra en un cráneo y defender nuestros
valores diplomáticos fundamentales y
radios me gustaría para darles las
gracias primer ministro por su decidida
iniciativa y su apoyo al pueblo de
ucrania que ha sido acogido más de lo
que piensa y pasamos a francia el país
se enfrenta a una crisis sanitaria ante
la escasez de personal clínico en los
servicios de urgencias esto por la
cantidad de pacientes que muchas veces
no son atendidos o se no se ven
obligados a esperar durante horas un
problema que el país arrastra desde el
inicio de la pandemia
alva santana nos amplia
confusos y desinformados unos pocos
pacientes esperan a ser atendidos fuera
del hospital universitario de burdeos
pero algunos no lo lograrán ya que ante
la falta de personal médico muchos
hospitales de francia han implantado un
horario reducido para acceder a
urgencias primero los pacientes deben
llamar al servicio 15 del samu que
decide si ingresan o no en función de su
gravedad y sólo entre las 5 de la tarde
y las 10 de la noche entre semana y
hasta medianoche los fines de semana hoy
en día hay muchos pacientes y sobre todo
no hay suficientes cuidadores así que
nos vemos obligados a restringir nuestra
capacidad de acogida y es que según
fuentes médicas el servicio de urgencias
de burdeos tiene una falta de entre el
40 y el 50 por ciento de médicos un
colapso de pacientes una situación que
el sindicato y otros colectivos llevan
advirtiendo desde hace meses
tenemos médicos que expresan ideas
suicidas médicos y cuidadores que se han
suicidado en francia- por esta presión
en otros puntos como en el hospital de
chino prácticamente todos los enfermeros
de urgencias están de baja debido al
agotamiento acumulado si no queda
ninguna enfermera y se empieza con la
reanimación el personal debe elegir qué
vida salvar y eso no es ni siquiera
imaginable en el hospital de lyon los
médicos y enfermeros están en huelga
desde marzo cuando un paciente murió en
un pasillo por el colapso del centro
ahora atienden los casos en los que
peligra la vida
llevamos meses incluso años advirtiendo
de esta desintegración del hospital
público en general y en las urgencias
esta crisis sanitaria es un problema de
fondo en el país y los expertos estiman
que si no se soluciona podría significar
el fin de los servicios de urgencias en
unos años
y terminamos con lo último del festival
de cannes el director coreano lee jong
joo es famoso por protagonizar la serie
de netflix el juego de calamar presentó
su primera película llamada hunt además
el director rumano cristian mungiu
regresó a la competencia con un filme
que confronta la xenofobia en europa
central rm n habla del drama de los
húngaros étnicos que rechazan a los
trabajadores de sri lanka maría carolina
piña periodista de rf y nuestra cadena
aliada nos cuenta más desde la riviera
francesa un thriller iraní y un drama
francés fueron los protagonistas de la
noche en cannes
[Música]
cómo
para el padre de fans
ya no
[Música]
nada nada
el jurado en cannes examinó la cinta
hole y spider del iraní ali abbas y una
película inspirada en hechos reales
sobre un asesino en serie en los años
[Música]
i
los hechos se desarrollan en la ciudad
santa de mayada donde aparecen muertas
varias prostitutas estranguladas por un
hombre que dice querer limpiar la ciudad
del vicio una joven periodista decide
investigar estos hechos teniéndose que
enfrentar a los jueces la policía y las
autoridades religiosas holly spider es
una dura denuncia de la condición de las
mujeres en irán donde conviven
patriarcado dominación religiosa y
misoginia
[Música]
la ítalo-francesa valeria bruni tedeschi
presentó en la competencia de cannes les
damos un 10 una vocación de una escuela
en un célebre teatro que dirigió un
monumento de las artes escénicas patrice
chéreau
añade
es una cinta fresca sobre muchachos que
aspiraban a convertirse en actores en un
momento donde reinaban drogas sexo el
miedo por el sida pero sobre todo el
fervor por el teatro en tu mundo
llevarla
sigan conectados con nuestra
programación
[Música]